[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a esta primera
crónica de cultura de 2022 en france 24
los artistas no son eternos y cada año
queda marcado por la muerte de algunos
de ellos pero en el espacio de unos días
el mundo de la cultura ha perdido cuatro
grandes figuras el más reciente el
diseñador francés thierry muebles a los
73 años tiene mi blog reino en la moda
en los años 80 haciendo de la híper
feminidad y del futurismo su seña de
identidad el director del museo de artes
decorativas de parís nos explica porque
el diseñador cambió el mundo de la moda
para siempre
transformarse en un cómic y vacunos fue
el primero que por fin transformó los
desfiles de moda y sobre todo los de
alta costura que a menudo eran un poco
aburridos en verdaderos espectáculos con
músicos a cantantes como diane rosen
así que es alguien que realmente a lo
largo de los años ha creado el
vocabulario contemporáneo de la moda que
se utiliza hoy en día en medio de la
semana de la moda por muchos diseñadores
sin siquiera tal vez pensar en ello
de la moda como espectáculo a la energía
espectacular del rockero estadounidense
mi klaus que falleció a los 74 años el
cantante llevó la música a lugares
salvajes y operísticos para convertirse
en uno de los artistas con mayores
ventas de todos los tiempos otra artista
mítica la diva de la samba y su voz
áspera elsa suárez murió a los 91 años y
desde entonces brasil ha rendido muchos
homenajes al talento y al compromiso de
esta cantante que creció en las favelas
pero yo de janeiro declaró tres días de
luto oficial para agradecer a esta
artista que tanto luchó contra el
racismo y la violencia doméstica
finalmente francia sigue conmovida tras
la brutal muerte del actor gaspar y el
de 37 años tras un accidente de esquí
sus amigos y colegas alabaron
unánimemente su elegancia su amabilidad
sus películas se quedarán marcadas por
su magnética presencia y su siempre muy
acertada y fina interpretación como en
hanibal el origen del mal
sanz lujo no es sólo el fin del mundo
porque ganó el césar al mejor actor en
seguimos con sigue en francés en el
festival my friend fin festival que
ofrece 30 películas cuidadosamente
seleccionadas en esta edición número 12
hay para todos los gustos y los estilos
les recomendamos en particular dos
documentales un país que se queda quieto
del periodista de luján que documentó
durante años con precisión y rigor la
violencia policial en francia y que
cuestiona en esta película la
legitimidad del uso de la fuerza en un
estado de derecho y sobre todo las
indias galant es una obra impactante
sobre la creación de una ópera con seis
cantantes y 30 bailarines the cramps the
fucking de flexión y breakdance un
diálogo entre la danza urbana y el canto
lírico que la película sigue desde los
ensayos hasta las actuaciones públicas
una mezcla de géneros que impresiona y
fascinada por su belleza y su poder
[Aplausos]
siete cascos y la visibilidad pero muy
débil y por selecciones
[Música]
[Aplausos]
todas estas películas están disponibles
con subtítulos y gratuitamente en el
sitio web de my friends fin festival
hasta el 14 de febrero en toda américa
latina desde ahora para quienes estén en
los ã ngeles pueden ir a descubrir la
exposición tupac shakur with me when i'm
free despiértame cuando será libre
explorando la carrera y el legado del
rapero estadounidense que fue asesinado
a tiros en las vegas' en
1996 a sus 25 años 3 de vídeos
esculturas es un viaje inmersivo por la
extraordinaria vida de este artista y
activista una exposición que también
pretende contar la historia de los
problemas raciales en estados unidos tal
y como los juntó tupac en sus letras
como demuestro tupac la música es un
medio excepcional para transformar una
experiencia individual en una colectiva
y esta es también la fortaleza del
primer álbum de la mexicana silvana
estrada después de un proyecto en 2017
junto al guitarrista charlie hunter
la cantautora veracruzana estreno
marchita un disco en solitario de 11
canciones todas personales y universales
a la vez un recorrido auditivo en torno
a la pérdida de una persona amagan que
trataba el duelo o la despedida lo
íntimo con la sensibilidad
característica de la voz de silvana
estrada como se puede escuchar ante
guardo
muy corta para entender lo que dicen tus
ojos que cuando los me
serían igual que los
pero no logro entender de qué van
pero si un día todo me encuentra sí
ahora piensa diferente
te guardo un poquito de break para abrir
los ojos y ver que nos despedimos con la
voz animada de all y alexander el
cantante llena de ante único miembro del
grupo británico james rangers su nuevo
disco night cold llamada nocturna acaba
de salir y esta canción sweet tour care
muestra perfectamente su dimensión son
chi y electro muchas gracias y cuídense
[Música]
[Aplausos]
con él
y éstas
mi padre es la cosa
acá
fin/2009
sí